Avoid Being Sued with the "Small Penis Rule"
The law is a funny thing and when it comes
to defamation and libel, it’s notoriously
murky.
As such, writers often have to be careful
when they’re trying to create characters
“inspired” by real people to avoid a lawsuit.
For writers who don’t care about that though,
there’s always the small penis rule.
In essence, the small penis rule is a way
of avoiding a claim of libel by describing
the libellous character as having a penis
of comically underwhelming size.
The idea being that few men would be willing
to sue if it meant having to stand up in court
and say that the character in the novel who’s
seriously deficient in his nether regions
is clearly based on them.
The earliest mention of the rule can be traced
back to a 1998 New York Times article by Dinitia
Smith, though the description itself is attributed
to libel lawyer Leon Friedman who describes
it as a “sly trick” used by writers looking
to avoid a law suit for basing a character
on someone who portrays them in a less than
flattering manner by simply giving them a
quality or attribute nobody would want.
Yes, the undesirable trait doesn’t have
to be limited to one’s manhood, and other
techniques for avoiding claims of libel may
involve things like:
Giving the character an unsavoury personal
foible like foul body odour
Describing the character as being ugly or
overweight
Making the character objectively abhorrent
by describing them as a racist or homophobic.
Going out of your way to make sure the audience
knows the character is into some really kinky
things in the bedroom
The idea behind all of these tactics is basically
the same- by making the character have one
particularly awful trait that nobody would
want associated with themselves, you can discourage
whomever that character happens to be a pastiche,
parody or mockery of from taking it to court.
That way, as long as you don’t use the person’s
real name, you’ll probably be fine.
A classic example of this occurred in Michael
Crichton’s book, Next.
In it, he describes a character called Mick
Crowley: (Warning, this one gets kind of graphic)
Alex Burnet was in the middle of the most
difficult trial of her career, a rape case
involving the sexual assault of a two-year-old
boy in Malibu.
The defendant, thirty-year-old Mick Crowley,
was a Washington-based political columnist
who was visiting his sister-in-law when he
experienced an overwhelming urge to have anal
sex with her young son, still in diapers.
Crowley was a wealthy, spoiled Yale graduate
and heir to a pharmaceutical fortune…
It turned out Crowley’s taste in love objects
was well known in Washington, but [his lawyer]—as
was his custom—tried the case vigorously
in the press months before the trial, repeatedly
characterizing Alex and the child’s mother
as “fantasizing feminist fundamentalists”
who had made up the whole thing from “their
sick, twisted imaginations.”
This, despite a well-documented hospital examination
of the child.
(Crowley’s penis was small, but he had still
caused significant tears to the toddler’s
rectum.)
This character, who is of virtually no importance
to the overarching plot, is also called a
“dickhead” later in the novel.
As it turns out, Mick Crowley was a very thinly
veiled stab at a journalist and Yale Graduate
called Michael Crowley who had previously
written a scathing review (which is no longer
available online) of Crichton.
Perhaps the “small penis rule” worked
in this case, as Crowley didn’t sue.
Instead, he wrote an article in which he stated,
among other things,
I confess to having mixed feelings about my
sliver of literary immortality.
It’s impossible not to be grossed out on
some level–particularly by the creepy image
of the smoldering Crichton, alone in his darkened
study, imagining in pornographic detail the
rape of a small child.
It’s uplifting, however, to learn that Next‘s
sales have proved disappointing by Crichton’s
standards, continuing what an industry newsletter
dubs Crichton’s “recent pattern of erosion.”
And I’m looking forward to the choice Crichton
will have to make, when asked about the basis
for Mick Crowley, between a comically dishonest
denial and a confession of his shocking depravity.
Crichton launched his noxious attack from
behind the shield of the small penis rule
because, I’m sure, he’s embarrassed by
what he has done.
In researching my article, I found a man who
has long yearned for intellectual stature
beyond the realm of killer dinosaurs and talking
monkeys.
And Crichton must know that turning a critic
into a poorly endowed child rapist won’t
exactly aid his cause.
Ultimately, then, I find myself strangely
flattered.
To explain why, let me propose a corollary
to the small penis rule.
Call it the small man rule: If someone offers
substantive criticism of an author, and the
author responds by hitting below the belt,
as it were, then he’s conceding
that the critic has won.